howdy everyone welcome back to another
episode of design patterns my name is
Matt and you're watching Code Tech
tutorials today we're going to be
talking about the template design
pattern and now this isn't what you
think when you initially hear template
if you're a C plus plus coder it's not
about templates and C plus plus although
in theory you could work that in but
that's not really what we're going to be
talking about now all really templates
are is it's a it's a method pattern and
it basically it defines some base stuff
and some required stuff that anything
that might use this will have to
implement is essentially a framework and
it has just a simple means of extending
some functionality using inheritance now
today we're going to use a bit of an
artificial intelligence theory here to
build up something uh that that might be
theoretically from a game and we're just
going to do this all in C plus plus so
if you're curious about how this works
and why it works just uh follow along
and see what you can get out of it but
it's something you see very commonly in
code especially game code but really it
could be anywhere it's just very easy to
expand once you get going and get a base
template going so when I say in template
I basically mean a uh an interface class
that has some default behavior and has
some things you must override and it's
basically a template for something we're
going to do a template AI so that many
different let's say units of a game can
use this base Ai and then change it as
they need to it's really good for an
algorithm it's some kind of algorithm
like when you think of a unit in a game
it's going to have some base algorithm
for what it does where it wonders where
it goes but different ones will do it in
different ways and stuff like that but
really it could be used for just about
anything that might have some
straightforward base operations but vary
depending on what you're implementing
okay so enough elaborate let's get to
implementing so first of all you want
some kind of interface abstract class
and this just has all the base
operations so let's just go and I'm
going to be doing this all just in a
main I'll put all the definitions up the
top and we'll do our client code of
testing testing and client code down
here
so let's just get everything worked up
and talk about it here first do we need
to yeah we'll probably just use the
console here so let's get IO stream
prepared but our first class is going to
be the one you think of we'll just kind
of call this uh I
base Ai No I don't know I for interface
ah maybe abstract AI it doesn't really
matter you call it whatever makes sense
for your program but we're just going to
call this the abstract AI at this point
here and we're going to publicly Define
something like uh base operation void
base operation and uh sure we'll make it
cons because it's going to run some
stuff not gonna really change much and
this is where you're gonna
you know basically run all your code
like uh publicly run all your codes
going to run through all your templates
so something along those lines and uh
you see it has a
you know a section we're actually going
to Define this doesn't need to be
overridden although you can if you want
so let's uh keep going here
um no we're not going to override that
one we're going to leave it non-virtual
and then we're gonna have some
operations that you have to go through
so let's just theorize some for some
kind of game we'll say we're talking
about units you know maybe you got enemy
units maybe you got friendly units and
they all kind of have some AI I'm going
to try to keep this simplified though I
don't want to go too far you're going to
have to use your imagination for how
much further you could go so let's just
go with uh
uh maybe a scan operation it always does
some sort of scan right
and we could have a base scan uh it's
essentially
gonna do do nothing the bass isn't
really gonna do anything here so we'll
have to override that all right so we're
not override it rather but well you'll
see we'll get to it later scan isn't
necessarily a good name because it's
like scan what scan maybe we'll call it
scan map if it has like an area around
it it knows about it can scan that and
just uh pulls some details for later and
then maybe we have a second operation of
a move unit and we'll put that one in
here and then we'll put in another one
uh
attack sure
so there we go we got some some basic
stuff that we're going to need to to use
and now let's define some virtual stuff
that you're going to need to override so
virtual void
let's think about this that's this is
stuff that we definitely have to
implement uh maybe we have to implement
the scanner for example I don't know
just hypothesizing some stuff here I
should probably make this a little more
generic I guess if this doesn't go as
well as I think it will maybe I'll redo
it but okay we've got a scanner and what
else will you have something else we got
a mover Maybe
uh yeah sure or maybe we'll call this
assist or something I don't mover's fine
I think for now and now we want some
stuff that has uh some base things but
not necessarily
the uh these don't necessarily need to
be overridden we'll say so definitely
have to override your scanner and
definitely have to override your mover
for example but you don't necessarily
need to override these ones and we'll
call this um
I gotta give them some kind of name for
now I'm just going to call them hook one
and maybe we'll rename them later and
this one just has a base of doing
nothing uh so
Works a little boy and we'll do a hook
of two
so by default these do nothing uh but
you can override them it's just not
required you're only required to to move
these so uh and you know also let's
override the attack because you gotta
implement the attack right definitely
instead of hook I'm gonna call these
special
one I like special sounds better because
you know the units are going to have
special abilities and stuff like that
maybe two different abilities is good
for that all right so actually scroll
back up here and go to this base
operation this is basically what's going
to get called from our classes that
implement this abstract AI so we need to
have a bit of an order here so maybe we
could say the first thing we do is we
scan move and then attack so we just
basically go scan map new unit
then attack
and we could have some other little
things in there like our required
overridden things here I guess scanner
is kind of a bad name here uh maybe you
know just since it sort of overrides
this but I guess what we could do is
just go into scan map and put the
scanner here
and then here I'll put the Mover
but you could also just have an order
here and not not Nest them you don't
have to do this nesting thing I'm just
kind of uh
hypothesizing a bit here so this would
call scanner this would call mover and
this would call maybe uh oh we got
attack in here multiple times uh maybe
we'll call this uh s attack for special
attack or something like that well I'll
spell it out special back
so it'll just call special attack now
notice that you have to override it so
you'll see you know there's there's some
different ways you can do this um and
most of the examples I looked at
actually didn't have these nested but I
just kind of like this idea of doing the
nesting a bit and separating it out but
this is kind of the point is uh you have
your base operation okay got that and it
does its base things and it definitely
calls the overridden stuff and you have
some stuff that still doesn't
necessarily need to be overridden it'll
just be defaults
uh that don't do anything but you can
decide that on your own like uh
you know maybe let's
yeah this is fine for now we'll go off
of this it's a little janky it doesn't
doesn't necessarily uh do exactly what
we do what we think well let's put let's
put special one up here too and special
too
all right so by default clearly these do
nothing but the thing is that's a little
tricky is uh these specials could in
theory happen during a scan maybe your
unit has a special scan operation so
maybe let's actually delete these uh so
that when we override scanner we could
put specials in there and stuff like
that but I guess you could do that
anyway with the one you override all
right so I might be over complicating
this and that's it's easy to do because
we're not we're just hypothesizing we
don't have an actual game or anything
like that we're just kind of spitballing
some ideas and that's why it's gonna
seem a little a little awkward and
abstract and it's I guess the point but
if you have a real game and you know
what it's supposed to do you've got your
design in mind written down this should
be a lot more obvious as to how you want
to abstract it but basically you want to
have all the most bass stuff that
everything's gonna do uh in these parts
and then you want to have all the
special stuff that whatever you're
implementing could do override these so
there's always as base order follows a
space template if you will and
then when you implement your real ones
you're gonna you're gonna get some stuff
like that so let's just for example say
what about uh
yeah yeah we're definitely gonna just
hypothesize some here all right so what
if we have a base unit and we say it's
uh we'll just say ranged Ally All right
so this is on your side and it's an ally
and it's got some range so we could say
something like that and of course it's
going to implement our I abstract
AI like so
and now we need we definitely need to
override these so visual studio should
be able to assist us in this way let's
see if it does
protected
uh let's right click here go to Quick
actions Implement your virtuals and it
pops them in there excellent all right
so that's those ones we so you
definitely have to override these since
they got the equal zero so what does it
do for the scanner now we don't have a
map to work off of in theory or game you
know have you have a map and your
scanner might do some things with the
map but we're just going to uh put a c
out here for now
so we're going to say
ranged Ally scans map
and uh we'll just put that that's that's
all we're going to do for there right
now
um I don't think we necessarily need
this virtual word but we'll leave it
there that seems to be what Visual
Studio does by default it's uh I believe
it's optional in these though and uh we
could do this too we can go ranged Ally
um
yeah so we need a little bit of uh we
might do an if statement Siri and we say
if uh
uh enemy and range for example like you
know something like this oh we don't
have a true thing you know we'd have to
put some uh some private stuff here like
uh
private tool enemy and sight we say in
sight and people aggressive you know set
these two balls to begin with but as you
scan you might do some stuff so just in
theory you know if you set your little
your little unit to aggressive it'll go
attack stuff in sight if it's not
aggressive it might just like stand and
look at or something so that's something
you need to decide I'm not going to put
the aggressive in here that's that's
getting too complicated but I imagine if
I were making a game I'd put something
like that in there but let's keep it a
little a little simplified so if enemy
let's just go straight to enemy Insight
enemy if enemy in sight
uh we'll attack it
move to range and attack
or shoot rather I'll say shoot fire
weapon buyer maybe fire weapon fire
weapons however you want to do it range
unit detects
enemy and you know no let's let's go a
little further here like obviously we
don't have a map but we do have in our
old utility over here some random so we
could say you know just just for Demo's
sake that sometimes we see them
sometimes we don't so let's put a 50 50
in here and uh toggle this based on the
50 50. um just just to give it some
variety when we run so let's go ahead
and do that so what we're going to need
to do is go to our cmake be sure to
include uh
the backup directory here or you could
go cmake Rooter we just want to be sure
to path to this utility folder which is
up in directory and then in utility so
we're just going to go cmake I forget
what this is uh let's okay it's uh cmake
Source dur that gets you to the root of
your top level cmake which is here so
cmake Source dur and uh then we'll go in
to the utility folder like so make sure
we type this correctly and then we want
uh ran.cpp and uh same thing let's be
sure to put quotations around this so it
doesn't get infused
and same thing with the dot h now uh
basically all this does you probably
already know but in case you don't
um if we refresh this cmake
and then you know we put this in uh
cmake view cmake targets view when we
look at our let's see where is it I
guess it might not be in here yet yeah I
guess we gotta hit save and refresh on
our cmake here for it to pick it up oh
let's put it in the subdirectory design
patterns template now I should pick it
up after we hit save and this and
generate just a little cmake stuff there
now we should see template in here and
there it is and we'll see we'll see all
these files now that they're properly
included in the cmake so while it might
still work if you just include the
header correctly and it won't show up in
your cmake if you don't do this in your
target cell uh good practice to do that
otherwise you're going to run into
problems later all right so we got Rand
in there now of course we need to be
sure to include Rand which is back a
directory under hilli Target or include
directories rather I guess I'll include
this in the tutorial directories
template and then you know we just put
this path here there we go
and now in our main we don't have to go
back we just actually just go ryan.h
it'll it'll know what we're talking
about now we seem to have an error
somewhere oh we need to put public or
private here let's just do private okay
now it should be fine all right back to
where we were so yeah we got we got
random in here now so we can randomly
say maybe we detect it or not so we'll
just go uh if
um let's look at our Rand Library real
quick see which one we need uh let's get
uh zero or one uh this function zor
random integer zero or one that's a true
or false uh so we could go boom zor
so sometimes it'll be true sometimes
it'll be false uh let's say if it's true
then enemy Insight equals actually
rather than an if we could just directly
go like this
boom now it's going to equal zero or one
um why doesn't it like this must be a
modifiable value it is definitely a
modifiable value I don't know what it's
talking about all right so we'll just
ignore that squiggly there because
Visual Studio sometimes just isn't good
at life or anything
but yeah that should be fine maybe once
it casted to a bull I don't know what
the problem is nobody does uh
all right so there we go we got a
scanner it's going to randomly decide if
uh if it's in range so
uh you know we could say we'll put a
little if statement in here real quick
and just say let me get site
and we'll just put another C out just
for verbal clarification uh
fines you know me and here we go that
looks pretty good still don't know why
this is confused expression must be a
modifiable value we'll say you have to
get the enemy in sight
um
uh moves to range ranged Ally
moves to range and you know maybe we
could even put like something like us
you know we'll just say the scanner
operation let's just make this very
clear in our console scanner
just put you know a little Dash in space
like that action space like that range
dialy moves to attack we don't need to
put ranged alley in there a bunch we got
that at the top of our little block as
we'll see here shortly we got special
attack now so special attack will once
again say if enemy in sight uh now we
could go a little further here and say
if in range because you know maybe every
tick you're just moving you're not
necessarily attacking yet so let's do a
bull enemy in range it's false and then
we can go uh so we're moving
moves to attack range enemy you know
this might not necessarily go to true
but let's just set it to true in this
case here just for a once again sake of
example if enemy in sight and enemy in
range then we can say fires fire the
weapon okay so fire the weapon so what's
it do does it do any special attacks we
could do we could say special you know
we could go special one boom and special
two or we could do these in certain
situations based on
you know what we're doing now by default
these do nothing they're not going to do
anything at all unless we override them
uh so if we want those to do things
um we'd have to override them so special
one we could say okay maybe our ranged
unit on kill uh restores hit points or
something I don't know that's it could
have a special ability like that so
actually let's just do crit
we'll just we'll just make this special
the actual damage or the actual attack
so we could just go uh
we could say let's just do a 50 chance
of crit for example that's a pretty high
crit chance but it's fine so we'll just
say if this is uh ends up being a one we
create 0 9 though
we'll say
attack with possible crit chance special
that that's that sounds good to me for
now uh we'll just say crits
oh
otherwise it doesn't crit so we'll just
put an else here and just
you know maybe we could even do we could
do this differently we could do like
third chance of a miss a third chance of
of not so we could go like uh
let's find another let's find another
function here let's go zero
two one random so that returns a float
if we look at this function this is just
a function I made it basically uh
returns something between zero and one
so we can use that as a percent chance
uh we could say if this is greater than
point
66 7 then it crits
uh Elsa well you know let's let's get
this seed sorted out here temporarily uh
we'll just use an auto here it's going
to be a double uh and we'll call it roll
zero two one random
you know we could also go
um there's another function here that
might even be better that just uses
integers like this one and Decay we
could do do a one and a hundred so
getting into a little random Theory here
and you can design this how you want
zero to one is fine uh let's just let's
just go into K there we go
so we can say if roll greater than 66
maybe we'll do 67. you can decide what
you want your chance to be here uh we
could do alsif roll is uh
greater than 33. now these are going to
use some short circuit Theory as in if
it's greater than 67 it's going to do
this one and skip the rest if it's not
it's going to check if it's greater than
33 and then we'll say hits and otherwise
if it's less than 33 it's just going to
be we'll say it's a miss all right
misses
all right so there we go we got a little
bit of AI going on there we got a little
special attack attack with a possible
crit chance and maybe you know if we
have a special two we could do that as
well but maybe it doesn't have a special
two but we could we could put some in
there like if needs reload doesn't fire
instead reload we don't necessarily need
to override a special we can we'll just
leave it there you know it's not going
to do anything it's going to call this
blank one it's going to be the point
there we do need to make sure we got
this right yeah that looks fine
um but you know you don't have to not
everything's gonna reload so you don't
necessarily want it in the base so maybe
you just have your own function
somewhere and when you override stuff
you use it so maybe you've got somewhere
privately here like uh Rob reload or an
ammo count or something like that you
know and ammo account
equals Tylenol four let's say it's got
four shots all right we can do that
so we could call you know when we can
just put this in the special one logic I
suppose if uh ammo count is less than
one then uh
then call the reload function and don't
attack we skip our attack so we'll put
an else here
there's a couple different ways you
could design this particular block that
I'm working out here with this reload
functionality so however you want to do
it like for example instead of else we
could just put a return here to skip
over the rest but uh you can decide how
you want to do that but let's make a
Reload function and you can see that
yeah it's going to miss its account it's
a it's going to miss the it's not even
going to shoot if it reloads so instead
we'll just make a private reload
function so nothing can call it except
it tries to attack and needs a Reload
that's kind of janky because you should
reload when you're not in combat too but
yeah we're gonna forget about that for
now let's just make our reload function
and just all it's going to do is set our
ammo count back to four when we call it
now since it's private it has to be
called from one of these specials or
something which should be fine so uh
there we go now what we want to do is
just give this a run
um let's go ranged La you can in theory
make a uh
a melee one two and all that stuff maybe
it doesn't have ammo maybe just swings
so as you can see he would design you
know if you did a melee one you would
still use this abstract AI but you
wouldn't you know you'd be able to
design it you wouldn't have to reload
necessarily and uh you know you could
put different private variables
etc etc so let's just go ahead and
instantiate a ranged Ally and we'll just
call it a ranged Ally
um I guess we don't need to give it
anything to instantiate it's just gonna
it's gonna have these defaults here and
we've got any other defaults uh no
that's pretty much it
um but we can we can say a little more
maybe maybe we'll put some stuff here
just some more one and attack all right
let's try to compile this and see what
it does set this as template let's hit
our little play button and just see what
we get
okay we do have a bit of a problem here
uh let's see what kind of Errors we're
getting
must have a modifiable l value oh it's
because these are const see I'm uh we've
got some const functions in here that
I'm making a little a little awkward for
us because now we're holding variables
and uh
maybe these should be a little different
okay so you know we could we could
remove the const could remove all these
cons so we're just going to get rid of
all the cons that's a quick hack
um because that's that's how we're
designing our particular one looks like
we got to get rid of this const on these
as well because they're calling
non-const functions that's just a C plus
plus thing you if
you have a const function it has to call
other const functions in their bodies so
yeah that's just something I was
overlooking when I was talking earlier
but our compiler really settled it for
us and there we go looks like nothing
really happened there and that's because
we didn't do anything we need to call
this base operation for it to start its
thing so we'll go here we'll go arranged
Ally arranged Ally
dot base operation that'll you know we
call that every every tick of its update
basically we'd want to call this all
right so there we go we could step
through it we'll see it scans the map
arranged Ally scanner says finds enemy
in sight uh we go to move unit moves to
attack range goes to attack fires weapon
hits in this case so we run it a few
times we'll see that sometimes it'll
Miss probably there's another hit
uh finds enemy hits okay so sometimes
we'll get
nothing okay well it didn't say anything
because we don't have a else here but
basically if it doesn't find an enemy it
should say something like uh no enemy in
sight and I guess you know the way that
that these uh hop in there they kind of
kind of mess up the idea I had
or how it would look in the console
because they're popping in the middle uh
yeah there we go let's hit play again no
enemy in sight range alley scanner no
enemy doesn't do anything else as you
can see there finds an enemy moves fires
misses uh so you can you can see we get
some some cool stuff going on there now
as a little practice session for you is
see if you can do this same thing but
put in the melee guy and then put an
enemies and go from there but you can
see this is the template method where
you have this just base stuff and then
you override all the the specials as you
go and that's pretty much that's pretty
much the uh the template pattern the
generic template pattern not the C plus
plus template that's a whole different
thing but that's generally how you
template some stuff is you just have
that all the bass things and then as you
make specials uh you uh override what
you need to and go from there and it can
be really good for things like AI all
right I hope you've enjoyed the episode
and learned something and uh yeah I
guess I'll see you in the next one peace
out guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]